oh my gosh that's all three guys I
cannot start all three
I'm Antonio Cromartie and there's a
start bench good I will be giving a
category we have to start start one
bench one cut one I will start Friday
Night Lights that's high school football
that's just something that's very big in
that state of Texas I love it and you
got to put boobie miles in the game baby
my bench will be remember the site I
think there's a history behind Remember
the Titans I just I just loved how one
the atmosphere the storyline behind it
Rudy I would cut I didn't really get
into you know it was just something that
was not my type of field of a movie but
you know but that's just me start my
starter tequila gotta have my dealer you
know from from from my cats are zoo but
Don Julio 1940 to 1942 whatever maybe
gotta start with that that's my favorite
vodka I would have to benchmark some
facts not really a vlogger person
anymore but you know I'll go to that
before I go to that would be my second
choice definitely start to whisk not a
whiskey drinker more about bourbon so
there it is
that's all three guys I cannot start all
three I will start SuperSpeed separately
some [ __ ] oops got you get to
everything quicker I gotta worry about
traffic I ain't gotta worry about none
of that
so then three hour would [ __ ]
definitely simple fact just and I will
cut super straight I don't know if I got
speed I got to deal with okay start with
the wings I always gotta have wings
gotta make sure you gotta have your
favorite difficult to arrange the ranch
sauce ranch always with my always with
my wings peace who I would bench cuz PC
you always have I think I've something
that you always a tire when you're
having a pointy having a Super Bowl
party still a deal
I'm gonna cut I'm not eating those seven
layer dip this give me some queso some
chips and I'm good to go for me start
it's gonna be Carl two three let's just
sum up my pink one a little a fan from
the song so that's just always been me
so the [ __ ] is gonna be the blueprint
that's just that's a classy you gotta
have that on the [ __ ] this occasion
started don't work cut get rich or die
trying' it's a great it's good but I
didn't really get into this much because
that wasn't just my field at that point
in time I'm starting all three and the
reason I'm starting all three is because
they all agree at what they do and
everything is for it it's all of that
you know coming from a black background
and who I am all three of them are play
at the highest level and it's being
considered
all-time greats and every single one of
their
that's everything one of the sports you
can't take that away from so also we
have to be on starter from me
no [ __ ] no cut all through y'all my
starter I'm in southern for Marty
this was start [ __ ] cut